- [Mark] Okay, hi.
- Hey.
- [Mark] What's your name?
- Kaitlin.
- [Mark] Kaitlin.
Kaitlin, where are you from?
- Indiana.
- [Mark] What part of Indiana?
- [Kaitlin] Muncie.
- [Mark] How long have you been in L.A.?
- [Kaitlin] 15 years.
- [Mark] And what got
you to come out here?
- My baby daddy.
- [Mark] Your baby daddy, okay.
- He's from out here.
- [Mark] Oh, okay.
So you have a baby?
- I have five.
- [Mark] You have five kids, oh my God.
(Kaitlin laughs)
So where'd you sleep last night?
I saw you on the sidewalk
here early this morning.
- Yeah, I didn't sleep.
- [Mark] You didn't sleep?
So your kids are where?
- They're with family.
- [Mark] They're with your mom?
- My family.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So basically what your,
tell me what your drug
of choice is down here.
- [Kaitlin] Crack.
- [Mark] Crack, and how long
have you been doing that?
- [Kaitlin] I've been doing
crack on and off since '03.
- [Mark] '03, that's a long time.
- [Kaitlin] Yeah.
- [Mark] How do you make money?
- [Kaitlin] I'm a prostitute.
- [Mark] Prostitute, yeah.
And the guys that you pick up down here
are what kind of guys, all kinds?
- [Kaitlin] You get all
kinds of different guys.
- [Mark] Yeah, does it
get dangerous sometimes?
- [Kaitlin] Sometimes.
- [Mark] I've heard crazy stories.
- [Kaitlin] I mean, it's
just the basic hoe stories.
They're all the same.
- [Mark] Yeah, and how
much money can you make?
- [Kaitlin] How much do I make?
- [Mark] Yeah, on a good night.
- [Kaitlin] I made up
to $1000 off of one day
down here before, yeah.
But I mean, on an average,
I make about $300 a day.
- [Mark] $300 a day.
How old are your kids?
- [Kaitlin] How old are they?
My oldest is 19 and my youngest is nine.
- [Mark] Wow, you started early.
- [Kaitlin] Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] And where do you eat?
The shelters here, or?
- [Kaitlin] Oh, fuck no.
(Kaitlin laughing)
- [Mark] Okay.
- No, no, I mean, I eat at restaurants.
I eat out, McDonald's.
- Okay, yeah, all right,
in this neighborhood, you never know.
- Yeah, I mean,
most of the time I eat junk food, so.
- [Mark] Right, so what,
you got into drugs at what time?
High school or something like that?
- I've been doing drugs since I was nine.
- [Mark] Nine years old, really.
- I had some pretty wild sisters.
- [Mark] How'd you first
get introduced to it?
- My sisters.
- [Mark] What did you start with, pot, or?
- Yeah, yeah, I mean,
well, my real mom,
I was adopted,
but my real mom,
she used to smoke weed,
well, had me smoke weed with
her because I was too hyper
and it calmed me down.
- [Mark] And do you feel
like you have it control
or is it something that controls you?
- No, I have it under control.
- [Mark] You have it under control.
- I quit whenever I wanna.
It's not an ongoing thing for me.
- [Mark] You smoke it?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Have you ever stopped?
- Several times, yeah.
- [Mark] So why do you choose to go back?
- This last time,
I relapsed because I
went through a separation
with my husband.
- [Mark] So you're divorced
now, or you're still married?
- I'm still married to him,
we're cool, we're best
friends or whatever,
but we're not together,
we've been separated for a while.
- [Mark] What advice
would you give your kids
if they were here?
- I'd prefer not to talk about that.
- [Mark] Okay.
- I keep my kids in reality,
I don't really lie to them
or bullshit with them about anything,
so I don't think I really
have to give them advice
because they already know,
they see it first hand.
- [Mark] They know your
situation out here?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you talk to them often, or?
- Not in the past few years, I don't,
just because they're getting, well,
my two older ones,
I talk to more now
because they're 18 and 15,
or 19 and 15.
So they got more
understanding or whatever,
but my other children
are kinda at the age
where if you're not steady
with that or whatever,
then it can affect them and
school and different things,
so I kinda backed up from them for a while
until they get a little bit older
because I know that my lifestyle
right now could affect them in a major way
because this is kinda
like a point for them
that directs their life, so.
- [Mark] Did you ever
think when you were younger
that you'd end up in this situation?
- Doing what I'm doing?
Fuck no, no (laughs).
- [Mark] Where do you see
yourself in five years
or 10 years?
- Definitely not doing this.
No, I'm not sure.
That's a question that I can't answer
because I take everyday as it comes.
- [Mark] And what are you
most afraid of down here?
- Down here?
- [Mark] Yeah, or just in your whole,
where do you live?
- Where do I live?
I live down here.
- [Mark] You live down here, okay,
so and it's a rough neighborhood.
Is there something in the
neighborhood that scares you
or just your future, or?
- No, I mean.
- [Mark] Or that your kids
will get into this, or?
- I'm not really scared of people,
I worry more that something
will happen to my boyfriend,
my baby daddy,
than I do me.
I mean, I jump in and
out of cars everyday,
so I know that at any point,
something can happen bad,
and that's just something
that I've accepted with that.
My biggest fear period in life though
is that I don't like big cats.
Lions, tigers and bears,
I'm like (laughs), yeah.
- [Mark] What's the craziest thing
you've seen happen down here?
If you're staying up all night,
I can guarantee you've
seen some crazy stuff.
- Yeah, I mean,
a long time ago down here,
a girl overdosed,
and my boyfriend had to just
let her go and she fell.
That was pretty wild for me,
I don't like that type of shit,
but she died.
And then I've seen some people
jump a person in a wheelchair, and yeah.
And that's kind of out for me.
- [Mark] Crazy stuff here.
- [Kaitlin] Yeah, it gets pretty rough.
- [Mark] Well, take care
of yourself out there,
it was really nice talking to you.
- You too.
- [Mark] Thank you for sharing.